okay squad listen up there's more than
one way to end a game with sports ball
there's the walk off home run
the sudden death goal
the buzzer beater
but within the adrenaline adult psyche
of the american sports fan can any of
them produce a heart attack like a
successful hail mary pass don't answer
that it's rhetorical
why are hail marys special because
they're unicorns since 1975 there's only
been 28 of them in professional football
why because they're almost impossible to
get right to complete a hail mary the
past needs to be long like thrown from
midfield long with little or no time
remaining on the clock and you need to
be losing and the pass must lead to a
touchdown that results in at least a tie
but preferably a win that is a hail mary
most quarterbacks are likelier to marry
a supermodel than to throw a successful
hail mary in their career exhibit a tom
brady
so how did this play which practically
requires an act of god to come to pass
see what i did there easy with a prayer
hail mary full of grace the lord is with
thee
so it's december 28 1975
50 yards from the end zone but needing a
touchdown to win
cowboys quarterback and devout catholic
roger starback whispers a hail mary to
himself hell mary full of grace the lord
is with thee and launches a desperation
pass to receiver drew pearson the
cowboys win and the hail mary is
christened forevermore
any questions good now go win me some
ball games